au coeur de la ville la médiathèque 1994
une architecture originale et avant
gardiste le zénith d'orléans 1996 une
salle de spectacle en forme de dôme qui
fit couler beaucoup d'encre 2013 le fera
le fonds régional d'art contemporain
trois hommes ni architecturaux audacieux
et futuriste le ton d'une exposition
gratuite
orléans reçoit la crème de
l'architecturé pour la biennale
parmi les jeunes pousses camier elie
étudiante en master 2 d'architecturé de
se découvrir une façon de travailler
donc aussi bien des représentations
graphiques ou de maquettes qui exprime
un espace donc comment on peut organiser
ces espèces là on a vu qu'à beaucoup la
question de l'asile
la vie de futurs donc comment est ce
qu'on n'en cloisonne l'humain dans des
sortes de cellules et aussi comment
l'architecte travaille avec le client
avec les habitants ces deux étudiants de
23 ans ans représentatives de la
féminisation de l' architecture 70 % de
filles en fin de cursus et pourtant
c'est quand même difficile aujourd'hui
d'être une femme dans ce milieu d'hommes
et que
il faut qu'on marque notre place c'est
même notamment dans les questions de
chantier etc
on a peu de crédibilité et ça c'est pas
normal parce qu'on a de plus en plus on
est de plus en plus de femmes en études
donc c'est pas normal donc du coup voilà
on est dans ce perpétuel combat montrer
notre place et dire qu'on est crédible
nous aussi on n'a pas besoin d'être un
homme pour être fort en construction
pour connaître des détails de
construction tout ce que l'architecturé
compte de visionnaire et de grands noms
se donnent rendez-vous à la biennale
d'orléans
jusqu en août 2010 8 car demain se
dessine aujourd'hui